gratitude because they are way more
blessed than we ever was they had way
more and learning to parent with more
was the thing I didn't know
I want them to have compassion and
empathy I want them to be independent I
want them to be able to stand on their
own two feet not depend on us and the
very important thing I want them to know
that their happiness is up to them that
the world doesn't owe them anything and
neither does anybody else and control
happens when you know how to make
yourself happy where you know how to
create your own Joy so those are some of
the things and what comes with that are
boundaries expectations
um uh giving them responsibilities
handing them their lives early you know
not not being afraid of allowing them to
fail standing back and letting them sit
in their failures